est ce la pelle aventure ou bien
l'esprit de solidarité
ce rendez vous est donné aujourd'hui par
les associations de canyoning à vraiment
mobilisé touristes comme martiniquais
tous bien décidés à se jeter à l'eau
pour cette initiation
ça c'est un mousqueton le sud un
descendeur d'accord le descendeur ils
vont apprendre là haut à l'approché sur
la corde
et du coup c'est lui qui t'aidera à
descendre
sur la corde et la cascade vous sentez
lionel eu un petit peu craintif mais ça
va aller
hippocrate pourquoi c'est la première
fois
la première fois le canyoning qui vous a
poussé à venir là on avait du monde il
est descendu les premières appréhensions
sont toujours un peu stressante mais ça
va je pense que ça va aller on a l'air
d'être bien encadré
pour cette première approche du
canyoning c'est un petit parcours qui
attend les débutants après une courte
marche en forêt de descente en rappel un
saut puis à nouveau rappel aujourd'hui
le bouton récompense les audacieux et
même si les gens m'ont parfois la
tremblote la satisfaction est grande de
dépasser ses appréhensions
dans ce paysage idyllique en arrêtant un
petit tremplin
mais bon une fois prenez en bas ça va à
qui on est entouré de plein de belles
personnes donc ça fait par midam c'est
impressionnant quand même a été
impressionnant mais voilà pourquoi la
paix sur sainte hermine est ce que ça
donne envie de recommencer
oui pour les trois associations et le
club des gendarmes qui organise la
journée c'est surtout l'occasion de
collecter des dons pour un pays ami la
dominique paradis du canyoning
aujourd'hui à genoux on y va souvent
c'est une île qui est
très riche pour le canyon avec beaucoup
de bosses beaucoup de nature beaucoup
d'eau donc on a eu l'occasion de faire
plusieurs stages et leur situation nous
nous attriste du coup on a essayé de
faire quelque chose pour pouvoir leur
rendre service comme on peut à notre
niveau
une bonne action plus un défi à
l'arrivée chacun se sont un peu
différents c'est un super de super
sensations il est d'abord un beau
paysage
derrière cette cascade y en a d'autres à
plus haut qui sont légales sont
magnifiques le sentiment de découvrir un
pays aujourd'hui
oui totalement en martinique la pratique
se fait toute l'année mais à la
dominique toute activité totalement
suspendue depuis le cyclone entre
amateurs une opération coup de main est
envisagée prochainement pour aider les
clubs amis à équiper de nouveaux leurs
rivières